The 2000 Presidential Election between the
former Vice President, Al Gore, and then-governor
of Texas, George W. Bush, was extremely close,
with only 500 votes in the key swing state
of Florida separating the two candidates.
Many people today look back on Bush's win
in 2000 with skepticism, citing the fact that
the vote counting in Florida, where Jeb Bush
was governor at the time, was halted before
all the votes could be tallied, leading the
supreme court to pre-emptively award the presidency
to Bush.
In fact, the 2000 election has been called
a turning point in the decay of American democracy.
However, in the world of the SCP foundation,
Bush's presidential win in 2000 wasn't just
an example of shoddy ballot counting and senate
bias, but the result of a strange case involving
alien parasites, body-switching, smear campaigns,
and farting cows.
Yes, you heard that right.
This is the story of SCP-4444, and the entity
simply known as “Garber Gore.”
SCP-4444 was first discovered in 1999 by Agents
Ringwald and Porterhouse of the FBI's Unusual
Incidents Unit, also known as the UIU.
Ringwald and Porterhouse had been tasked with
monitoring the phone calls of then-president
Bill Clinton.
Clinton was having a conversation with Joe
Andrew, who was the chair of the Democratic
National Committee.
Joe was calling to report a couple things
about Vice President Gore - first, that he
was going to announce a candidacy for the
2000 presidential bid, nothing too unexpected
about that.
But then he told Joe that there was an alien
in his head.
This was followed by a white house staffer
witnessing him walk right through a solid
wall.
Given the strangeness of these claims, the
UIU moved in to attempt to contain the vice
president.
However, this proved to be a tricky situation,
because as Joe had stated, Al Gore was able
to walk through any solid object.
Unsure what to do, the UIU called in the SCP
Foundation for some much-needed backup.
The nature of Mr. Gore's anomalous properties
were such that it prompted the Foundation
to create an entirely new containment class,
of which SCP-4444 is the only example.
The new class, Ticonderoga, was named after
the Iroquois word for an intersection of two
rivers, and fittingly, the new containment
class represented an object that was in between
being contained and not contained.
SCP-4444 was to be monitored, but not apprehended,
as any attempt to do so would only aggravate
his anomalous properties.
During the initial monitoring stage, Al Gore's
home was scanned with infrared cameras in
an attempt to discover what might be causing
the anomalies around the vice president.
What they found was surprising - a long hexagonal
spike engraved with alien glyphs, invisible
to the naked eye and apparently intangible
as well, was protruding from the back of Mr.
Gore's head.
Even though Al Gore could not be contained,
the SCP Foundation was still able to interview
him to try and ascertain the nature of the
spike and the anomalous properties it caused.
Present for the interview were Gore himself,
SCP Site Director Alex Mabel, and FBI Associate
Director of Special Units, Adam Spironi.
Initially, Spironi was uncooperative, and
Gore himself dismissed Director Mabel's claims,
but midway through the interview he started
to emit a strange noise, like a radio being
tuned.
Wondering if this was the spike trying to
get in contact, Mabel asked “Is anyone else
in there?” to which he got this response-
“Wonder nuts.
Name of Garber Gore.
Presented?”
Mabel tried to respond by introducing himself,
but Al Gore interrupted by addressing the
entity in the spike himself- “Well hang
on now, Garber.
I haven't done proper introductions yet.”
Through the rest of the interview, Gore explained
his situation.
The entity in his head called itself Garber
Gore, and while it could communicate verbally
using his voice, there was a translation barrier
that meant that its speech patterns and syntax
were often unintelligible.
Gore had been aware of his situation with
Garber for just a few days, but in that time
the two of them had formed something of a
bond.
In fact, Garber was the one who convinced
Gore to run for president in the 2000 elections.
Mabel asked Garber what it wanted on Earth,
to which it responded- “Mindthink the sustenance
of Garber!
Salacious desire undertaking encouragement.
Downsize the conquest.
Strongest most strong.
Garber Gore presented misunderstanding.
Strongest misunderstanding "Vice" unequated.
Goofy unnecessarity for implementation Garber
Gore on the think-stem.
Improvement situational by majority gathering
selectors the vote.
Garber Gore succeed presidential, encouragement
arrival the greater Garber.”
Al Gore was quick to translate Garber's mangled
speech.
As far as he understood it, Garber had been
sent out as an emissary for his species of
inter-dimensional, planet-hopping, parasites
that feed on thought.
Garber's intention was to implant himself
in the head of the most powerful person on
earth in order to facilitate an easy colonization.
Garber's species were non-violent and unable
to stand up to any kind of resistance, but
if the leader of the free world was already
merged with one of them, it would make taking
over the planet that much easier.
However, in a misunderstanding of Earth culture,
Garber had gone for the Vice President instead
of the actual commander in chief, Bill Clinton.
Now, Garber's plan was to fix that mistake
by having Al Gore win the presidency.
The SCP Foundation obviously couldn't let
this takeover go unchallenged.
Even though Garber's race were peaceful, seeking
only to use the thoughts of the human race
as a food source, further interviews and studies
revealed that they emitted insanely high levels
of carbon dioxide.
To have a large number of them merged with
the human population would spell total climate
chaos, essentially hot-boxing the Earth to
the point it could no longer sustain life,
even faster than humans are doing it.
Since there was no safe way to remove the
spike from the back of Al Gore's head, more
drastic measures had to be taken.
In a meeting with the FBI, SCP Site Director
Crow presented a possible solution - an Incorporeal
Entity Vacuum Chamber,
which the Foundation had seen some success
with in detaining ghosts and other apparitions.
The only problem was, anything placed in the
chamber would explode.
And, since Garber couldn't be separated from
Al Gore's head, the results would be messy.
Since the FBI was unwilling to blow up the
vice president, that left only one choice:
the SCP Foundation had to find a way to turn
American voters against Al Gore.
It wouldn't be easy to do so without attracting
suspicion - in fact, it would be almost impossible
unless they were able to put a man on the
inside.
Thankfully, just such a person presented themself.
During the meeting, the FBI delegates let
the SCP Foundation members know that, while
it hadn't been leaked to the press yet, George
W Bush was in a coma in the hospital after
being hit by a stray bullet during a hunting
trip.
His body was relatively undamaged, but doctors
had little hope of recovering his mind.
At this point in the meeting, all the SCP
personnel present turned to look at Dr. Bright.
He was going to be their inside man, whether
he liked it or not.
The Foundation visited the hospital where
Governor Bush was being cared for, and moved
him into foundation care before he could be
pronounced dead.
There, doctors finished patching up his body
and SCP-963 was applied, allowing the spirit
of Dr. Jack Bright to take over his mind.
Jack Bright, masquerading as George Bush,
was now ready to run for office.
The next step in the process was to start
a disinformation campaign against Al Gore.
There were a few proposed smear campaigns
to be used against Gore.
The first proposal was codenamed Tarbelly
- a campaign that would have the Foundation
blame Gore for the pollution of the water
supply in a rural part of the developing world.
This one was dismissed for being too outlandish.
The next was Porky, which involved a rumor
that Al Gore had once been caught in a compromising
position with a pig.
This one was dismissed due to not having access
to convincing photo editing software.
The third one was codenamed Star Wars and
it involved discrediting Al Gore by saying
he believed he was in contact with aliens.
This was obviously shot down very quickly
due to being a little too close to the truth
for comfort.
The proposal that was eventually settled on
was codenamed The Other Monica, and the story
centred around the idea that Monica Lewinski
was just an innocent patsy taking the fall
for the person who Bill Clinton had really
had relations with…
Al Gore.
This rumor was the perfect combination of
salacious and being just believable enough,
making it the perfect thing to use to smear
Al Gore's reputation in a country that still
hadn’t come around on gay rights.
While Director Crow continued to refine prototypes
for technology that would allow the Foundation
to interact physically with SCP-4444, the
Foundation staged an early September debate
between Gore and Dr. Bright posing as George
Bush.
The idea was to create a controlled atmosphere
and mitigate any potential security risks.
The debate was held in a church in Plainfield,
Indiana, and moderated by Jim Lehrer.
During the debate, Garber Gore did a lot of
the talking for his human host, resulting
in some utterly incoherent responses.
When asked what makes him more qualified for
the role of president than Governor Bush,
Gore responded - “When you see someone sitting
in that chair, you want to know for sure that
they’re the best ambivalent vicarious corncrake
caliper available for the job.
And you can be sure that a vote for Garber
Gore is an understandimated vote for respectability,
neutrality, lamp posts.”
In the middle of the debate, an audience plant
brought up supposed leaked photos of Al Gore
and Bill Clinton engaging in their illicit
affair.
The crowd was understandably shocked, yelling
and screaming in response.
Now that the crowd was against Al Gore, Dr.
Bright went in for the kill.
He asked the people in attendance - “Do
you want to see a strong man in the chair,
or a weak man under it?”
At this point, something weird started to
happen to the people in the crowd.
They started full-on rioting, but then, they
started to change shape.
In fact, the whole space started to shift.
Al Gore stood up and started waving his arms,
shouting - “Garber unacceptable addition
convention terraform unto dark magicianship!
Spell!
Spell!”
People rushed towards the exits, but found
them blocked by the elongated forms of other
members of the audience.
At this point the church was raided by both
Foundation personnel and the FBI.
Garber Gore fled from the scene, returning
every attendee to normal as soon as they were
out of Garber's line of sight.
The debate was pulled from television, and
anyone who had watched it live was administered
amnestics.
Additional amnestics were administered to
anyone who saw Garber Gore running through
solid objects as he fled from Indiana to western
Ohio, where he was found hiding in the loft
of a barn.
Meanwhile, Dr. Bright was punished by the
ethics committee for his behavior during the
debate, and agreed to act more in a professional
manner for the October debates.
Most of Al Gore's campaign team were undercover
UIU agents who used audio editing to iron
out some of the eccentricities of Garber's
way of speaking before putting ads out.
Most of them were able to be saved in the
edit, but some were so off-the-wall that they
could never be shown to the public.
In one of them, Al Gore stands in a field
of cows and talks about how much greenhouse
emissions are produced by farting cows.
He then gives his solution to this problem
- taping plastic bags over the backsides of
every cow in America.
Another rejected Garber Gore campaign ad that's
much shorter but just as crazy features a
video of a sleeping cat, with Al Gore narrating
about how everyone should shave the backs
of their heads.
On November 7th, 2000, election night, the
SCP Foundation and the UIU watched the results
with bated breath.
If Gore won, they'd have to be prepared to
use Director Crow's new vacuum nulifier device
to simultaneously contain SCP-4444 and kill
Al Gore.
The SCP Foundation had killed public figures
before, but never a president on the eve of
his election.
But then, Florida started to tip in favor
of Bush.
After two days of recounting, despite losing
the popular vote, Doctor Jack Bright in the
body of George W. Bush was named President
of the United States.
The Foundation expected an outburst from Garber,
but the entity remained silent.
In fact, Al Gore has never displayed anomalous
properties again.
He conceded defeat graciously and more or
less retreated from the public eye until the
release of his film, An Inconvenient Truth.
That wasn't the last the SCP Foundation ever
heard of SCP-4444, though.
On November 11th, 2007, a mysterious broadcast
aired on TVs across Gainesville, Florida that
appeared to be a lost Al Gore campaign ad.
It shows Gore sitting on a hill by the sea.
In the distance, something large drops from
the sky.
Al Gore smiles and says, “I’m Al Gore,
and I want to be your last American President.”
Now go check out “SCP-1981 - Ronald Reagan
Cut Up While Talking & SCP-095” and “SCP-3166
- Monster Garfield Attack” for more SCPs
behind the scenes of real life events!